okay let's get into audience questions
first one very timely very important
david the federal eviction moratorium
is ending soon what is going to happen
when all of these people get
evicted in the next few months well
that's
that's not going to happen actually i
think it's important to
let's contextualize it yes i believe
july 31st is actually the day that the
federal eviction moratorium that's
coveted related will will come to an end
but there's a bunch of different reasons
which explain why you are not going to
see
nearly even a majority of the people
currently
in theory in in at risk of getting
evicted get evicted
dean baker the economist talked to us
about this last last week he said
the number being bandied about is about
eight million people could get evicted
but that he believes in reality it will
be more like eight hundred thousand and
as he said it doesn't mean we don't care
about the eight hundred thousand
but eight hundred thousand evictions uh
nationally
is not necessarily going to be a major
economic disaster
doesn't mean we don't care about the
people doesn't mean we we don't need to
fix the situation so there's a few
different things that you have to
remember
first of all depending on what state or
even city you
live in the fact that the federal
moratorium guidance from the cdc
ends on july 31st doesn't necessarily
impact you because there are states and
in some cases
even cities that are choosing different
dates so there are already some states
with moratoria
or moratoriums colloquially that are in
place that will go longer
and two of the states or some of the
states with the largest populations like
california texas and new
york have protections that go beyond
july 31st
already both for residential as well as
for business evictions
you've got other states like illinois
oregon hawaii
new jersey washington new mexico they
have
their own guidelines in place that go
longer than july 31st
texas has local eviction moratorium that
has been
extended to i believe it's october 1st
or maybe october 31st
so the there's the idea that on a single
day
all these people are going to get
evicted the reality is many states have
already extended that
the other reality and this doesn't help
people
it's just from an economic shock
perspective it's important
it takes a long time to evict people and
it takes a different amount of time in
different
municipalities it can take months and
months to evict
people um i know uh various lawyers that
work on evictions both with tenants and
with
landlords often it's the same lawyers
that work with both not in the same case
but work with both
they say depending on the state you you
could take three to even six months
depending on if it's a place where it
gets cold in the winter there are even
bigger restrictions in place all the
time
so there's not going to be a single day
of evictions now one
additional factor here california and
new york
have announced programs where they are
going to pay
past due rent for a lot of people who
are at risk of getting evicted
so in those places when the moratoriums
finally do
end there aren't going to be mass
evictions
because the states have put in place
these
programs so for me the bigger question
is the following so many people live
paycheck to paycheck
you miss one paycheck you miss a payment
for your rent you can essentially never
catch up
there's an emergency you've got a health
insurance plan with a 2 000
deductible and something happens where
you've got to pay the 2 000
all at once and so you miss a rent
payment
you essentially can never catch up and
that is a bigger reality that
whatever you feel about paying past due
rent like california for example put in
place doing even if you feel like that's
the right thing to do or whatever
um even getting a lot of people out of
the current situation imagine someone
who's
behind on rent because of the pandemic
lost their job now they're
kind of keeping up but they're not able
to catch up um
they're going to end up statistically
anyway some percentage of them are going
to end up back in that situation anyway
because so many people are living
paycheck to paycheck
that's not going to change even with
rent forgiveness the last thought on
this
there are people who say that because
real estate prices have become so
overblown in many parts of the country
that an eviction
and even a foreclosure crisis would be
a really good thing it would pull down
prices
and um that is not necessarily wrong
in some states but there's a question as
to whether we should
hope for the misery and stress and
anxiety
of being evicted as a path towards
a modest reduction in housing prices
which may or may not even be permanent
um so that's kind of a bigger discussion
but that's the bottom line on evictions
they're not going to happen all at once
not that many are actually going to take
place and you've got to really pay
attention to what's happening in your
state and in your municipality
in particular one of our sponsors is
steadymd
primary care the easier and more
affordable way to do
primary care and they're giving you 50
off because you are in my audience
you just answer a few questions steadymd
will match you with a licensed primary
care physician that's tailored to your
needs
you'll have a one-hour virtual
appointment and start
a meaningful relationship with your new
doctor
and from then on your doctor will be
available to you by text phone
and video chat it's not some random
doctor on call
your steady md doctor has a limited
number of patients
you get the attention you deserve and
they can help you with anything your
primary care doc
normally would it's very cool how it
works
you don't need insurance it's just 99
bucks a month
no other fees or co-pays for visits take
the free quiz
and see which doctor is a perfect fit
for you you'll get fifty percent off
your first month when you go to
steadymd.com
pacman no risk no long-term commitment
the link is right underneath the video